[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUIM GIL: This
year Summer of Code
was very special because we
went from 9 students to 19.
And that was great, but at the
same time we were a bit scared.
Can we handle that?
But the results
were pretty amazing.
When you do this big
jump, basically doubling
the number of projects
you're taking,
you really need to get
organized in a different way.
You need to be more systematic.
You need to rely on a lot more
on the mentors themselves.
Each team must be
more autonomous.
But we kind of managed.
BRADLEY KUHN: Looking at our
organization, The Software
Freedom Conservancy, we have so
many different member projects
in so many different areas
of free software development.
The mentor summit
is the place that I
can come to see all of
them because they never
go to the same conference except
for this one, because GStock
has done such a good
job at bringing together
all these different
free software projects
and getting them to talk
to each other in ways
that really no other
program today does.
ROSE ROBINSON: We found
an incredible amount
of just science projects,
humanitarian projects,
a lot of server projects,
which were really
cool because a lot of
sisters are actually
into those type of technologies.
So I think they would
be very excited to see
that for next year.
QUIM GIL: Just after few weeks,
our Summer of Code students
were not Summer
of Code students.
They were just regular
members of our community
using exactly the same
channels as the rest of us use.
And also we are very happy
about the small detail, which
is important, which is
seven of those students were
women, which was very different
scenario of any previous years.
HARLAN STENN: Google
Summer of Code
has helped us to bring to
fruition several projects that
were just big in scope.
And it's also helped us
with a number of projects
where we just needed
somebody for a few months.
And they can sit and
punch something out
and focus on it for a while.
MICHAEL DOWNEY: So our goal is
to save the world, essentially.
And GStock has really been
able to give us the opportunity
to do that and to help
our students do that.
And so we're looking
forward to continuing
that mission in years to come.
KAREN SANDLER: And I think
free software generally
is indebted to Summer of
Code, both for helping
how it has with the
outreach program for women,
and both in sponsorship and
in organizational inspiration.
And then also with
Summer of Code
generally, because we've
had so many great newcomers
from Summer of Code, I can't
even begin to tell you.
We've had so many
great students come
in that have become invaluable
members of our organization.
I was talking to one
of our board members
a couple of months ago.
And he was telling me that.
And I asked him, how did
you get involved with GNOME?
And he said oh,
well, Summer of Code.
And I had no idea.
He is essential to
the GNOME community.
And we would never have had
him if not Summer of Code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]